- Welcome back everybody,
We've got Chiara Aurelia,
Mila Kunis with us.
Give it up.
(clapping and cheering)
- Together, they star in
the new Netflix movie,
"Luckiest Girl Alive".
It starts streaming tomorrow.
Also, joining us now is the
woman who wrote the book,
and was an executive producer
on the film, as well.
Please welcome "New York
Times" bestselling author,
Jessica Knoll.
(clapping and cheering)
- It's amazing to me 'cause
your name sounds like
a character in a book.
- We were just having a little bit
of a name conversation here.
- Yeah, but your name
sounds like the, like,
lead character in a novel.
Jessica Knoll.
- I'll take it, thank you.
So, this book and the movie
are based on your real life,
which, while watching, was
a real struggle for me,
and I think most people when they watch it
'cause it's very intense,
and to be that vulnerable
and open is a very next level in your step
of progressing as a human.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause a lot of people,
and I know, honestly,
far too many people that
have had trauma happen.
- [Jessica] Yeah.
- And it- they don't- they're
still like 40 years old
and haven't been able to get through it.
- Yeah.
- And so it's incredible.
So, I'm just saying thank
you for all those people,
but how did you find the
courage to tell that story
or own that story in life?
- I mean, I don't think at the time
that I sat down and
began telling this story,
which was 2013 at my kitchen table
at my apartment in New York City.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I don't even think I was thinking beyond
what I was doing in that moment.
And I was doing it for me.
I had finally found a
way to put on the page
this thing that had haunted
me for most of my life,
and I did it under the cover
and the protection of fiction.
Like, that was really important.
Like, I wasn't- I wasn't ready yet
and I was too frightened by my own-
by what had happened
to me when I was young.
The way that it was mis-characterized.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And the way I was blamed for it.
I was still so scarred
from that, that I was like,
"I'm gonna put this in a work of fiction
and then I'll let the public decide".
If they call it rape,
if they call it assault,
then I'll know, finally, I'm
validated that I feel this way.
And so, for the next year
after the book came out,
every time someone would say to me,
just in passing not even realizing, like,
"oh that assault scene
was so difficult to read",
or like, "you rendered
it so realistically,
how did you do that?".
I'm, like, you don't know
what you're giving me.
Like, you're giving me the validation
that 15-year-old me sought and didn't get
when she needed it most.
- Yeah. Wow.
- [Jessica] Yeah, it was
a really powerful thing.
- Yeah. So you also wrote the screenplay,
which, Mila and I, we were talking about,
most people don't do, like,
most authors don't do.
- No.
- Did you really- I mean,
'cause I find I, if it were me,
I would find it hard to
let go of that character
in somebody else's hands.
- Yeah. Well at the point that
I- that the book was optioned
and we were even talking about
it being- becoming a movie,
I still hadn't written
my essay where I came out
and said that this had happened to me.
So I think I still felt
so wildly protective
of this character and
this voice and this story.
And the idea of someone else tackling it
and writing it made me crazed.
Like, I couldn't stomach the thought.
I was like, "I have to
be the one to do this"
- [Kelly] Rightly so.
Yeah. Yeah.
- What conversations
do you hope this movie
opens up for people?
Like what kind of dialogue?
- I mean, I woke up this
morning to a message
that my agent passed along to
me from a 57-year-old woman
who said that she picked
up my book at the airport,
and she was, like,
"I don't even know if this
message will ever get to Jessica,
but like, you know,
something happened to me
when I was young", and she
shared it with me and she said,
"even if you never see this,
just putting this on the page
has been a therapy for me I
didn't know that I needed".
'Cause she hadn't talked about it
- And she's 57.
- Yeah, so I hope that's what happens
with the book and the essay.
So, if it were to happen on a, you know,
such a broader scale,
which is what a platform
like Netflix can offer,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I, you know, I just think
that's such a great thing
for the world and for women at large.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- What about you guys?
Like, what conversations
do you hope kind of-
'cause you're a different
generation from us, right?
So like what do you hope this kind of-
'cause do you feel like your
friends are open enough?
Do you feel like your generation is open?
She's like "oh no".
(laughing)
I just mean, is it- is it hard
for you to talk to your friends?
Like about, like, serious matters?
It was harder for me whenever I was a kid.
- [Jessica] We didn't talk about it.
- You didn't talk about anything.
Everything was under the rug swept.
There's a whole line about it
in Alanis Morissette's song.
So yeah, I was like, she
knows, but is it easier?
I feel like your generation-
like even my nephew,
he's 20, the same age as you.
He is way more progressive-
- [Jessica] Yeah.
- Than I am.
Like, I mean, and I'm pretty progressive,
but he's just more, I guess not,
progressive isn't the
word, more open-minded.
- [Jessica] Or articulate.
He's more open-minded, he's
okay with talking about things.
- They have this language
that, like, I did not have-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- At that age.
But we've kind of talked
about that, right?
- We've talked about this a little bit.
I mean, I think something
that's like really great about,
you know, the time that we're in now
is people are becoming more aware.
They're willing to have conversations,
they're hoping, you know,
they're trying to learn.
Does that mean that we're in the place
where everything is fixed
and we're, you know,
everyone knows exactly how
to handle the situation
and, you know, talks about it regularly
and is totally, you know,
educated about the situation?
I don't necessarily think so,
but I also think that people are trying,
which is what is the biggest
change that has happened.
- It makes me hopeful, your generation.
Like even talking with my nephew,
I spent the whole summer
with him and I was like,
"I'm sorry, when did you grow up?".
(laughing)
- "Luckiest Girl Alive" start
streaming tomorrow on Netflix.
And the book, also called
"Luckiest Girl Alive"
is available wherever books are sold.